(audience laughing)
- Thor's Hammer is out
here sitting on the stage.
What's that all about, Andy?
- I don't know, I noticed it earlier.
I just figured you would know what it was.
- No! I come out here
and there's Thor's
Hammer just sitting here.
We can't do a show with
that thing sitting there.
It's stupid, you know?
It's in the way!
I'm gonna get rid of it
right, should I get rid of it?
This thing's gotta go!
(audience cheering)
Should be easy.
(grunting and straining)
Come on, man!
- [Audience] Conan! Conan! Conan!
Conan! Conan! Conan!
- I'll give it a try.
- Yeah, try that.
- [Audience] Andy! Andy! Andy!
Andy! Andy! Andy!
- Hey, let's both--
- That was a mistake.
- Let's both try it together.
- All right.
- Try it together, okay?
Let's get in there.
(audience cheering)
- We're not gonna do it.
- I guess neither of us is
worthy, I think that thing's--
(lightning strikes)
Wait a minute.
(dramatic orchestral music)
(audience cheering)
- What's up dudes? What's going on?
- Hey, Will Arnett,
what are you doing here?
What's going on?
- Not much, I was just dropping by
and I noticed that I left this here.
That's so funny, yeah.
(audience cheering)
- Okay, you gotta stop,
stop hamming it up.
How did you do that?
- What?
Oh, dude, I'm Thor.
(audience laughing)
- You're Thor?
- Yeah, Conan, everybody knows that.
I'm Thor and...
(audience laughing)
I'm also Lego Batman.
(audience cheering)
Check this out. You ready?
- Uh huh.
- Lego Batman.
(audience cheering)
Thor.
(audience laughing)
Ready?
- Yeah.
- Lego Batman.
(audience cheering)
And now I'm Thor.
- Yeah, okay, all right.
That explanation went on way too long.
(audience laughing)
- I see why Thor has to overcompensate.
(everyone laughing loudly)
- He's an easygoing dude.
- Yeah, tell us what
brings you to Comic-Con.
- Dude, are you kidding me?
Do you know how much tail
Thor gets at Comic-Con?
It's unreal.
(audience laughing)
And you know how much
Lego tail, Lego Batman--
- Okay, I don't wanna--
(audience and Andy laughing loudly)
No one wants to know about that.
- Yeah, anyway, listen.
Thanks for keeping her safe,
I really gotta run man.
I got a date with 20
Harley Quinn's and, uh,
just kinda wondering
if they can handle it.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, I can handle it.
I mean, I'm BoJack
Horseman for Christ's sake.
(audience cheering)
(lightning striking)
(dramatic orchestral music)
- Will Arnett, everybody.
Catch, Will Arnett.
(audience cheering)